this is part of the cruise experience we
almost never eat Moviefone cookie but I
forgot it so doesn't matter and the best
part is you get to drop off the kids we
are on vacation
[Music]
all right we made it officially in
Florida Lena subscribe to hidden clue
channel look at them is there any
pimping out his channel on mine mr
Hayden says he's gonna be a what would
you grow up
movie producer he's getting this
practice we're gonna wait for our
cousin's our family and then to
[Music]
let's see how hot it is let's see how
hot it is go go outside okay tick it off
that's some t-shirt weather nice eh what
do you think mister
[Music]
terminal G celebrity Qin ox we have
arrived what do you think mister we made
it you ready to go alright
no drones beyond this point good thing
we're not using a drone
[Music]
all right the first two key cards have
become Michael Hayden Carmichael with a
very excited child ready to go and
partay
[Music]
who's excited Wow Wow
that was not a lot of excitement guys
first stop
Ledo get some nice broccoli for Hayden
yummy Richie wants broccoli too
yeah lots of broccoli are you blocking
this are we blocking each other our
cruise tradition we take the stairs
everywhere no elevators stairs only
you're hurting we're just starting the
kids are already complaining about
walking we just started
let's go we walked two flights of stairs
and you already tired the kids are going
to learn on this cruise all right we're
here 7 190 to go Annie Mike oh yeah all
right all right look at this we got oh
that's a we got decent sized bathroom
happening here you got a nice couch this
is some good this is some spacious
action we got a nice bed here I like it
a nice big balcony
all right downtown Miami in the back
picture up where's our TV oh there we
got Nina
when does the vacation start know when
you put CNN on come on that's MSNBC this
is the most important thing Fox
CNBC sky come on where is it where is it
no all right well we'll settle for MSNBC
I guess MSNBC CNBC what do you guys
think CNBC or MSNBC we are on vacation
ah
all right I have officially done the
shorts and the sandals which means it's
vacation time these guys still in their
Toronto where but
maybe a little change because we need to
go get some food
she's always thirsty no hungry who sees
Ledo
where's Ledo oh they don't have a lead
Oh probably 14 mass bar Ocean View Cafe
Ocean View bar
you guys probably 14x14 time to climb
stairs that's how we do it that's how we
do it kids let's go let's get some
stairs happening we're gonna climb lots
and lots of stairs and then eat lots of
lots of ice cream I thought you didn't
like food okay
well maybe the Huff candy
[Music]
name is ticking off we got a table got
some pizza round one
did you see the ice cream bar huge ice
cream bar this ice cream bar is legit
not just soft-serve with like a little
bit of caramel sauce so once you get a
few rounds of food in ice cream bar -
nice
wow you got cucumbers and and quinoa
that's actually pretty healthy better
than mine Wow I think you need to eat
more than that Missy here comes Nina
round one look at that oh I have the
shepherd's pie - nice enjoy Nina
the plate is empty that means it's ice
cream time
ice cream time you ready
[Music]
[Music]
Oh what's this how many scoops do I have
what do you have oh you gotta ask for -
my friend next time you added some
gummies that is the first round of ice
cream very very very excited let's go
find Nina we are going to the shore
excursion desk make sure we can get our
short skirt is done and I have something
to say but I forgot it so doesn't matter
I remember what I wanted to say now they
made an announcement saying that the
celebrity Equinox has the fastest
internet at sea which is very exciting
last time on our cruise ship I couldn't
even get on YouTube period so fingers
crossed this is half decent Internet
[Music]
what are you guys doing are you vlogging
what did you learn you're in it we had
the most right boat to go
[Music]
all right he's getting his b-roll in his
blog busy life of a youtuber here huh
hit him with your iPad you didn't bring
it to get your Pierrot
next time that's a gay boom alright next
up is to register the kids for the kids
program why was vlogging invented
because I don't know all you do they
just document everything you document
you take people on a journey you tell a
story and the best part is you get to
drop off the kids and the kids want to
be dropped off to this actually yeah all
the adults are just really sleeping on
the chairs
the adults are passed out on the chairs
and the kids want to play so we're gonna
register them
[Music]
all right so nobody registered so we're
going to the kids because they have a
light turn if she doesn't want to go
because meet my mom pop murmuring feels
Restless woman and she's like good are
you really embarrassed but I slim lit
once I want to see this mermaid Nina and
I we snuck away to enjoy a little two
little mini romantic castaway scenery in
time together the kids are gonna be
swimming but before that they wanted to
make some b-roll for their vlogs just
don't drop the phone over the edge guys
what are you doing mister vlogging I'm
vlogging the kids vlogging this is the
best vlog ever
this is the craziest vacation I've ever
been on
the boys are vlogging and Nina is just
relaxing on I think Nina's the smartest
one of all of us here
[Music]
Nina and I found the spot to relax check
this out
the benefit to probably watch the kids
there's still vlogging it's amazing
[Music]
the girls dressed up as mermaids look at
that
[Music]
alright it is time to go get some dinner
first dinner on the cruise
Nina is here in her first dress hello
nice dress Nina the boys are getting
dressed up look at Hayden in his fancy
shirt let's go have our first dinner
guys are you hungry
I am not hungry at all actually
but this is part of the cruise
experience we almost never even hunger
tea if we just always eat and then and
then we're gonna go for buffet
afterwards neenah desert
[Music]
you're the oldest one here Richie you
need to you need to take control be a
leader
[Music]
the editors hard at work not even not
even breaking over dinner to keep
working on their video the hardcore
entrepreneurs so in an interesting turn
of events the boys both on their own
ordered salad to start with and Nina and
I did you order a salad
we ordered escargot the boys are going
healthy and we are eating some serious
butter Ritchie put too much vinegar on
his salad too much vinegar hayden
meanwhile demolished his plate the ma
demolished his salad and he's suffering
with the salad but he's vlogging it
anyway
this is the best vlog ever
[Laughter]
oh this is real a French Chinese suit
and good alright I have shrimp all right
Ritchie's got his spaghetti tastes good
tastes good right they just got pizza
and fries Lena and I got the same thing
mushroom sauce and potatoes and green
beans so done with dinner
feeling pretty full Nina is gonna take
the boys and head up to the buffet to go
get dessert
only this is my favorite time but I'm
getting a little bit on the seasick side
maybe it's just that we haven't really
slept that much so I'm gonna head to the
room relax maybe pass out you have a
shower and ready for tomorrow
Keywest